november 22 marked the 50th anniversary
of president kennedy's assassination
coming up more from the duquesne
university conference on jfk's murder
next rex bradford the vice president of
the assassination archives and research
center he looks at the findings of the
church committee headed by idaho senator
frank church
the panel investigated abuses by u.s
intelligence agencies from the 1950s
through watergate
this is 50 minutes
hello
um
my talk is going to be a little bit
different i want to start with a kind of
a history lesson that
may hopefully will show some of the
context of what we're talking about it's
not directly about the kennedy
assassination although i'll be moving
into that as well
for the old hands in the audience i
apologize if some of this is familiar
ground
okay i would like to start by painting a
picture of a time
imagine this if you will there's intense
partisan rancor in washington
a controversial war abroad recently
wound down and in the midst of all this
a steady drumbeat of revelations about
intelligence agency abuses wiretapping
spying on americans
and even targeting of foreign
adversaries abroad for assassination
oh wait i'm describing 2013.
but the year i want to focus on
is 1975.
and this picture actually is from a few
years before but it may give you a
little bit of a flavor of the times
75 is the year after president nixon
resigned over the watergate cover-up
um although his paranoid governing style
had earned him many enemies not just
liberal institutions and democratic
leaders but also
on the other side
for example in 1971
nixon discovered that he was being spied
upon by no less than the head of the
joint chiefs of staff admiral moore
a navy yeoman named charles radford had
been stealing documents from henry
kissinger his
secretary of state um
anyway nixon's resignation
in 1974
was followed by a heavily democratic
so-called reform congress some of the
names you may recognize henry waxman tom
hart
hart
time hartman
and patrick leahy were elected in that
congress
and they immediately voted
funding restrictions on the vietnam war
which was already winding down but wound
down much more quickly
the new congress was also determined to
make government more open and passed the
government and sunshine act towards that
end
nixon had been succeeded by former
warrant commissioner gerald ford who
along with his chief of staff donald
rumsfeld and his aide dick cheney
wasn't on quite at the same page as the
congress
ford was not in a position of strength
at this time though um for example the
freedom of information act which had
been passed in 1966
but without the teeth to overcome
agency's stonewalling it was
strengthened in 74 and ford vetoed that
but was overridden by a two-thirds
vote of congress
um so this is the context in which
revelations of abuses of not only the
white house but also u.s intelligence
agencies fbi ci and others began to leak
out of washington into the nation's
newspapers
um
revelations that the us army had been
spying upon anti-war demonstrators
was followed by a major article in the
new york times in december of 74 by
seymour hirsch
in which he revealed ci spying
operations on americans and break-ins
and other activities on u.s soil in
violation of their charter
the ford white house at this point
immediately wanted to know what other
skeletons were in cia closet
and so within days ci director colby had
delivered a family jewels document to
the ford white house
some of you may know that in 2007 this
document was finally released to the
public
although much of it was old news at that
point and their redactions the blackouts
begin on the signature page
in any case it occlu it included
revelations of other abuses
including wiretapping of reporters
opening of mail
and assassination plots
now there have been rumors circulating
from time to time about assassination
plots against fidel castro cuba's leader
but it turned out it was president ford
himself who let the cat out of the bag
he was at a white house lunch with new
york times editors
and was asking there for their
forbearance and all these revelations
because quote it would blacken the
reputation of every president since
truman if they wrote about them
when quizzed about what he was talking
about he said like assassinations um and
the new york times editors actually
didn't publish this comment but it got
leaked to daniel shore who soon did
so what happened next is that ford
appointed his vice president nelson
rockefeller
and created a commission on cia
activities in the united states
but both houses of congress also quickly
followed suit with their own
investigations
now the rockefeller commission um
they did receive evidence of the cia
assassination plots but didn't take that
on as an issue
in general they conducted a pretty
circumscribed probe
former warren commission staff ex member
uh
david bellen was their executive
director
they did
publish a report about ci domestic
spying and mail opening
and they actually took on two questions
related to the of the assassination
one was whether now famous watergate
burglars e howard hunt and frank sturgis
were two of the three dealey plaza
tramps in disguise
and they also took on the somewhat more
serious question
of jfk's rearward head snap as seen in
the z brutal film which had been
recently shown for the first time on
national television
some of you may know that dr cyril wek
testified before the rockefeller
commission in that regard
but the limited focus rockefeller
commission was quickly superseded by
a body with a lengthy name which came to
be known as the church committee
after its chairman idaho senator frank
church and they really opened it up
they took on a full review of u.s
intelligence agencies
history and rationale as well as the
excesses and abuses
the senate committee was much more
aggressive than the rockefeller
commission had been although their style
contrasted with the much more
confrontational house representatives
[Music]
my green clickers oh there you go i can
only imagine what dick cheney thought of
new york congresswoman bella abzug
taking on the national security agency
so in the end the house's committee
report was actually suppressed by the
house and only put in the village voice
when daniel shore again leaked it
but the church committee went on to do a
year and a half long investigation
published 14 thick volumes of reports
some of them quite thick
and they the the bland titles here don't
begin to cover the range of topics that
they
they really took on
this includes
things like the fbi's
counterintelligence program
domestic disruption called cointelpro
their harassment of dr martin luther
king jr
joint fbi and cia mail opening programs
warrantless electronic surveillance and
black bag jobs by the fbi
um
a ci domestic spying program called
chaos covert operations this is cool
plotting in chile abroad and other
topics
in this talk
there's a there's a lot to
get into there and we're not going to
i'm going to cover two of the reports
and the investigations behind them here
the first is their uncovering and
documenting of foreign assassination
plotting by the cia
and the second is a limited review they
conducted of some aspects of the kennedy
assassination
and before we get started i want to say
that i think that what they did was very
valuable work um doing the detailed
documentation of the the plots to kill
castro on others
because i have no doubt that if not for
what the church committee did the whole
idea that the cia plotted against these
people would be one of these conspiracy
theories you hear about with pros and
cons and
reminiscent of some other matter that's
before us this week um
it's also striking how much i think
things have changed in america since
1975.
nowadays the us openly conducts drone
strikes against foreign adversaries uh
who senior officials call quote bad guys
and along with the collateral damage of
family members the associates who may or
may not be themselves bad guys in the
occasional wedding party
in 1975 by contrast it was a national
scandal
the very idea that the executive branch
of the u.s government would contemplate
targeted
killings abroad
okay so
who are our targets here
the church committee
right off the bat took on the cia
assassination plots as a priority
um conducted over 100 interviews to try
to piece together the story of executive
action and they focused on these five
foreign leaders this is fidel castro of
cuba patrice lumumba of the congo rafael
trujillo of the dominican republic
nego din ziam of south vietnam and renee
schneider of chile
in a footnote they noted that actually
he had received evidence about a couple
of other plots presidents of karna of
indonesia
and papadoctu valley of haiti but they
didn't take those on
but to its credit unlike many other
congressional investigations they were
dogged in pursuit of the facts on these
five cases
and we learned a great deal about the
genesis of the plots uh who was involved
with them and the command and control or
lack thereof in some cases
um
the church committee reached in some
areas some pretty solid conclusions and
other areas they uh the full truth was
quite elusive and they were willing to
admit that in their report
sometimes you may
hear i've seen this sometimes on news
programs the idea that these were sort
of zany ideas you know exploding
seashells or the the coat castro was
supposed to put on that would make his
beard fall out and embarrass him and
the impression is that these are sort of
zany uh things that were done keystone
cop style never came to fruition and i'd
like to counter that a bit by saying
that most of the plotting involved
machine guns and rifles and very deadly
poisons and four of the five people on
this list are dead only castro survived
but actually the committee itself uh
absolved the cia and u.s authorities of
direct responsibility and all for those
deaths
um and i want to go into that a little
bit uh they concluded the following
that uh the cia did dispatch poisons to
congo to try to kill patrice lumumba but
he was killed instead by congolese
rivals we'll see there's a bit more to
that story
rafael trujillo's dominican enemies were
supplied with pistols and carbons by u.s
state department diplomatic pouch
but the committee said quote there's
conflicting evidence concerning whether
the weapons were knowingly supplied for
the assassination and whether any of
them were present at the scene
um
vietnamese leader tsiem and his brother
were killed in a coup which the u.s
greenlighted um but in which the
committee found no evidence that the u.s
favored assassination
um
and general renee schneider was not the
leader of chile but he was a general who
was refusing to block the accession of
the elected leader salvador allende
which was
anathema to the nixon white house
um and he was killed in a kidnapping
attempt by uh enemies of his
uh so-called kidnapping and attempt
anyway
um but the committee said quote it
doesn't appear that any of the equipment
supplied by the cia decouplers until in
chile and this is machine guns we're
talking about was used in the kidnapping
there's no evidence of a plan to kill
schneider or u.s
officials specifically anticipated
schneider would be shot during the
abduction
okay so on the one hand i think it's
important that the committee
tried to get in the details and tried to
get the details right and not just say
u.s tried to kill these people they're
dead end of story
the leaders did have multiple enemies
although as we'll see there's a bit more
to the story in a few cases
um
but i think it's also important to see
the larger picture the trujillo and
schneider conclusions particularly about
direct responsibility are quite hair
splitting
and you know if you were to give
somebody automatic weapons to use in a
kidnapping but never dreaming someone
could get hurt and then lo and behold
they show up dead
try using that defense in a court of law
i'm not a lawyer in fact some of you may
be but accessory to murder is about the
minimum that comes to mind i think
the committee did something also
important in laying out the details of
the plot which is to try to answer the
question of who authorized them and that
was not an easy one for them and also
the command and control down to lower
levels as to how they were executed
and here they ran smacking against what
we call plausible denial
um
the committee wrote
uh
i read the whole thing they find that
the system of executive command and
control was so ambiguous it was
difficult to be certain at what levels
assassination activity was known and
authorized
um
so maybe
uh
plots were taken without them really
being explicitly authorized maybe
there's plausible denial and the
committee just was unable to penetrate
that and they basically
in the end that this was in large part
their answer to
that question
um the paper trail was somewhat thin
which is one of their difficulties
one of the they had to re rely mostly
upon interviews with various people
one of the few contemporaneous documents
is this one from william harvey who ran
some of the assassination plots at cici
under the codename zr rifle
executive action program
this document is fascinating to read it
includes some choice quotes such as
never mentioned word assassination in a
document he left behind
it also contains this amazing little
piece that i don't think you can read
here so i'll read it for you
cover planning should include provision
for blaming soviets or checks in case of
blow should have phony 201 file to
backstop this all documents they're in
forged and backdated should look like a
counter espionage file okay so there are
some 201 files that are now public but
back when this is written
the idea that any of these things would
even become known to congress never mind
the public was a little bit far-fetched
and so it's fascinating that within the
cia's own filing system the idea of
forging and backdating documents in
order to cover tracks was part of the
initial planning of the operation and
this is one of the things people trying
to use cia records and others to get at
the bottom of things you know have
it makes it tough
so importantly the committee also had
access to one very key document which is
a 1967 inspector general report that the
cia itself had undertaken uh when
pressure to do so by lyndon johnson
um
about the platzical castro
um
but much of it like i said still came
from interviews and one of their
problems was many of the important
people were dead john and robert kennedy
for instance were dead as well as
desmond fitzgerald and ellen dulles from
cia
and during the committee's investigation
itself more people showed up dead
sam giancana
who was part of the kestrel plots
was shot in the mouth five times before
being interviewed by the church
committee
and johnny roselli also a major part of
the plots did testify before the
committee a few times but then
disappeared and his body was found in a
55-gallon oil drum floating off the
coast of florida
so
on the basic question of whether u.s
presidents specifically eisenhower and
kennedy for the most part was the focus
authorized these plots
the committee ran headlong into an
impenetrable fog
one national security staffer named
robert johnson did say that he was at an
nsc meeting when eisenhower ordered
lumumba's assassination and he was
shocked at the time that this occurred
um but he couldn't remember for the
committee the exact words used um the
committee pinpointed a particular
meeting in which this had to be an
august 18th 1960 meeting
and indeed with until within a month of
that meeting a man named sidley gottlieb
of the technical services division at ci
had been to fort dietrich selected the
appropriate deadly virus and was off to
the congo
but the minutes of the meeting of course
don't reflect any of this and even
participants said of course the minutes
wouldn't
and his account was also disputed by
others or for the most part people said
well they just couldn't recall any such
thing um he wasn't really disputed quite
so directly
um participants in the plot like deputy
director of plans richard bissell
swore that they had authorization of the
top but of course they had no proof to
offer the committee of that
so in the end the church committee said
there's basically a few possibilities
here you know eisenhower ordered the
assassination but it's not in the record
record maybe he used a euphemism like
getting rid of uh lumumba with a weak
weak nudge nudge to ci director dulles
who's at the meeting
maybe he said something like that and
oop but he didn't really mean
assassination and oops alan dulles
misinterpreted them
in other words they they
failed to resolve the issue uh
completely
and compared with the ambiguity over
whether eisenhower ordered lumumba's
assassination the idea of whether
president kennedy was a part of the
castro plots is positively labyrinth
the discussion of several plastique
castro in the committee's report
is the largest section of the report and
the first one they documented although
there are indications there may have
been earlier plots but the first one
they documented started in august 1960
when
ci director deputy director richard
bissell contacted sheffield edwards who
contacted an ex-fbi agent named robert
mayhew who got in touch with johnny
roselli who got in touch with his pals
jaffa conti and giancana and the rest of
the so-called cia mafia plots which you
can read about
all over the place and many books is
history from there
um
the
church committee also wrote about some
of the zanier plots that i mentioned
exploding seashells and so forth
um
it's also worth noting i think there's a
set of plots that they might have
investigated but never took on um
there's a famous uh
incident called the bao pauli raid which
was ostensibly in the summer of 63 about
trying to get supposed military soviet
military personnel out of cuba but which
many people think was a cover for an
assassination team
and that wasn't part of the committee's
work
they also fidel castro
gave george mcgovern a black book of 24
plots against his life
and this book was passed along by the
church committee to the cia who
basically said yeah we know a bunch of
these guys we work with them we don't
know nothing about no assassinations and
the church committee essentially took
them at their word on that and they have
not have gotten the full story on what
was going on there
the last castro plot the committee
discussed in the report the so-called
amlash operation
is intriguing and is perhaps the poster
child for the dilemma that the committee
faced on the issue of authorization
um i want to give a little background
first in in 1963 of course it's the
aftermath of the cuban missile crisis
and kennedy's no invasion pledge
and cuba policy changed again
1962's operation mongoose of overthrow
from within was disbanded
william harvey who was heavily involved
in that and had ran a follow of rfq
during the missile crisis for
dispatching
sabotage agents into cuba during the
crisis itself
was demoted and eventually sent to rome
and the fbi began conducting raids on
cuban exiles who were
conducting operations from u.s soil
in particular after in march of 63
alpha 66 attacked a soviet vessel off
the coast of cuba
it's interesting the church committee
didn't really get the full story in the
then the second half of 63 and we know a
fair amount more although some of it
still remains a bit mysterious and i'll
discuss a little bit of that later
amlash
is a kryptonium or pseudonym whatever
i'm sorry i should know for a man named
orlando orlando cubella cicadas
um cubella had achieved some fame in
1956 for assassinating the head of
batista's
security forces in cuba and by the early
60s was an official in cuba's government
in 1961 he first approached the cia
about defecting
and was persuaded to stay in place and
importantly some say officers were very
concerned that cubella was a dangle
a double agent who would report back to
castro just being offered for that
purpose
but strangely nevertheless in september
of 63 after a year of no contact
a cia officer met with cabela in brazil
and there were discussions about
overthrowing castro which turned into
assassination
discussions
cubella however warned that he really
needed assurances from the higher level
and requested a meeting with robert
kennedy
now on september 7th on the very same
day that cubella's case officers are
cabling headquarters with this news from
brazil that cubella is willing to
attempt an inside job fidel castro shows
up at the brazilian embassy in cuba
and gives an interview with an ap
reporter and says
quote
oops all right backwards
u.s leaders should think that therefore
aiding terrorist plats to plots to
eliminate cuban leaders they themselves
will not be safe
a coded message perhaps
in any case what happens next is
extraordinary special affairs staff had
desmond fitzgerald in october uh met
personally with cubella and represented
himself as a personal emissary of robert
kennedy cabela told fitzgerald he wanted
a high-powered rifle in the end what he
got was a poison pen
which was delivered to him on november
twenty second nineteen sixty three
uh the inspector general report says
that they were probably meeting and
getting the pen at the very moment
kennedy was shot
cubella refused the pen
and it gets weirder who authorized
fitzgerald to represent himself as the
personal emissary of rfk
according to the cia's inspector general
report richard helms and fitzgerald had
a meeting
and helms decided it wasn't necessary to
talk to rfk
or seek his approval and when questioned
by the committee helm said he didn't
really recall the discussion but he
leave he believed he had pre-existing
authority for all this sort of thing and
so he wouldn't need to
and so this was the committee's nutshell
in a dilemma in a nutshell
you know for some people it's obvious
well the kennedys and the cas are all in
this together and they might have talked
off the record etc etc
but it's also true that cubella's
reactivation occurred right at the time
when john kennedy had begun opening back
channels of uh to castro using william
atwood and others as emissaries to seek
a rapprochement of some kind
and so it's interesting that fitzgerald
who didn't use his own name by the way
would use rfk's name in an assassination
meeting with a cuban whose bona fides
were in question and the possibility of
this getting back to castro was quite
real and indeed may have
so is it possible this was a game being
played to sabotage the rapprochement
meetings
the story of cuba policy in 63 is fairly
complex and wasn't really fully known to
the church committee there's the amtrunk
project which was a kennedy-initiated
overthrow project which people in cia
hated because it featured
hurray and manoa ray and the left-wing
side of the
anti-castro forces
there's also a project amworld which
involved manual our team and the
offshoring him to nicaragua and
for an eventual overthrow of castro from
outside and the church committee seems
basically unaware of all that
which is interesting and we we know a
lot more today
in the interest of time i'm going to
have to skip a little bit there's a bit
more on this whole issue of
authorization there's a famous meeting
the committee wrote about where robert
mcnamara himself clearly brought up
um
uh
the the concept and uh
it got written down in some memos and
people through fits over that
but i'm gonna
move on
does this green button work
okay
so the church committee reports were
published 38 years ago what have we
learned since then
regarding the lumumba assassination
there have been new developments
although some questions remain
in 2001 a belgian commission
congo had previously been a belgian
colony
admitted being aware of extreme danger
to lumumba's life and not doing anything
and issuing an apology
and a moral responsibility
but author lito dewitt has written
compellingly that their involvement
which went much further and that in fact
lumumba was killed by a belgian firing
squad
allegations of further cia involvement
in that operation have been made
beyond the failed poison pill plan
that cia station chief there helped
direct the search for lumumba when he'd
escaped from his captors that he was in
that they were in direct touch with the
killers that varied night and even a cia
agent had carried the body around in the
trunk of his car for a while um these
allegations have not been made the
subject of any uh government review that
i'm aware of
um in a very strange twist just this
past april
um the british a british house of lords
member named david lee wrote a letter to
the london review of books saying that
in 2009 he'd had a cup of tea with
daphne park
who had been british council and first
secretary to congo in 61
and when mr lee brought up the
controversy about lumumba's death and
whether mi6 might have been involved
miss park replied we did i organized it
and there it sits today i think
there's been no quite no quite so
explosive news about some of the other
murders although new details emerge in
any of these cases the schneider family
actually sued henry kissinger in 2001
although that case was eventually
dismissed
on the castro plots we have a much
fuller picture like i said about 1963
policy including
the simultaneous peace feelers as well
as ongoing plotting and sabotage
operations and it's a complex picture
my general take um although there are
subtleties here um but is that in 63
kennedy was far more determined to bring
about a peaceful world
um than the rest of his government was
uh whether it was being shaken by the
cuban missile crisis or as uh
someone once told me uh no no it was
that the cuban missile crisis gave
kennedy the political capital to do what
he wanted to do anyway
in either case things were moving on
several fronts it was a state secret for
35 years but now public that in the
spring of 63 plans for complete
withdrawal from vietnam were were drawn
up on black and white on paper they're
available online like many of this
from that to kennedy's
peace speech at the american university
in june which uh announcing a whole new
orientation toward the soviet union
which was followed up by nuclear test
ban treaty in the hotline
to these uh
peace feelers towards castro which were
being explored at the very moment that
he died
at the same time kennedy was a pretty
pragmatic and tough leader who certainly
didn't want cuba to be an issue in the
64 elections the vietnam plans for that
matter for instance were kind of too
cutely delayed for the most part until
after the 64 election as well for
political purposes
um and so i think he's willing to
proceed on multiple tracks and the
question about whether those
multiple tracks included uh
being aware of and condoning
assassination plots
remains with us to this day
and there's even a little bit more about
that there's there's a memo that i'm
going to skip over for time in which
uh rfk is quoted a little ambiguously
but very intriguingly about
opportunities offered around castro
the the the dilemma the church committee
face hasn't changed much but there's a
little bit more for people that are
interested to dig into
but i'm going to try to move on a little
bit towards the subject of our our
weekend here
okay
the second topic that i want to talk
about
is a sec another aspect of the
committee's work undertaken by a
subcommittee of theirs
um headed by senators richard schweiker
and gary hart
um the full name of the resulting report
is the investigation of the
assassination of president john f
kennedy performance of the intelligence
agencies
and the context here is this by 1975
it's 12 years after the assassination 11
years after the warren report a number
of books critiquing the single bullet
theory and many more aspects have been
written that are critical and they had
an impact but there was no federal
re-review yet on the momentum hadn't
built for that
but in july of 1975
a story emerged that lee oswald had been
to the fbi office in dallas and dropped
off a note which then had been destroyed
by agent hosty under orders of arms boss
after oswald was killed
and testimony was taken in the house of
representatives surrounding this
and uh one question remained which was
whether the contents of the note was an
innocuous complaint in hosties version
or a threat to blow up the fbi building
in the uh words of the secretary who
received the note and gave it to hosti
but in any case this was this was one
more uh chapter in sort of an ongoing
story of uh
serious questions about the warren
report and in particular whether the
warren commission had been served well
by the fbi and cia that they used as
their prime investigative arms
and this is the question that the
schweiker heart committee took
subcommittee took up
for obvious reasons one of their focuses
was uh why didn't anybody tell them
about the plastic castro maybe that was
relevant and in fact jaylee rankin the
warren commission's executive director
said yes that would have been very
relevant
um but they did more than that they dug
in it was a partial probe as we'll see
that didn't really get into the
assassination controversy uh the details
per se
but covered some important ground uh
particularly around what we might call
the cover-up
we've learned a lot about the federal
response to the aftermath of the
assassination over the years
particularly with the release of lyndon
johnson's phone calls in the 1990s
um the church committee helped to get
the ball rolling they published a
portion of this now famous memo from
nicholas katzenbach the assistant
attorney general
which he began drafting within hours of
oswald being killed and sent to bill
moyers at the johnson white house the
next day the day of the funeral
and it says in part the public must be
satisfied that oswald was the assassin
that he did not have confederates who
were still at large and that the
evidence was such he would have been
convicted at trial
now some defenders of this memo will
point out that that does open by saying
well it's important that all the facts
about the assassination be made public
um and katsubak himself was questioned
about this later during the house
committee and fumbled a bit and then
finally said well i don't think it's too
artistically worded
but artistic phrasing or not it doesn't
change one basic fact which is that on
the monday after the assassination
there's not a single person in the world
who's in a position to truthfully say
that oswald was the assassin and there
are no confederates i mean with ruby
shooting of oswald the day before
the smart money is on the opposite
conclusion
and so this is not a statement of any
facts at this time this is a policy
statement
and even even cuts inbox memo admits
this he goes on to say unfortunately the
facts on oswald seem about too pat too
obvious
marxist russian wife etc
so
the church committee also revealed that
in the aftermath of the
assassination uh director hoover
disciplined secretly 17 fbi personnel
for their failures in regard to it
and they dug a little deeper in some
other areas including the story of the
oswald trip to mexico city which i'm
going to talk just a little bit about
and about what we've learned much more
since
um in general though i think that the
the stories told by the committee aren't
as visually important as the overall
picture that they were able to paint
through them
and uh
they were careful to say that they
didn't dispute the warren commission's
conclusions per se having not reviewed
them but they were pretty stark about
what they thought was going on
um the committee has developed evidence
which impeaches the process by which the
intelligence agencies arrive at their
own conclusions about the assassination
and by which they provide information to
the warren commission the evidence
indicates that the investigation of the
assassination was deficient
and on the face the nation tv program in
1976 senator schweiker went further
he said the warren report is collapsed
like a house of cards the investigation
was snuffed out before it even began and
the fatal mistake the warren commission
made was not to use its own
investigators but to rely upon the ci
and fbi which played directly into the
hands of senior intelligence officials
who directed the cover-up
it's been a while since the u.s senator
spoke on national television about the
kennedy assassination cover-up but it
did happen
by the way on the subject that's been
brought up about what's missing from the
records we now have
a subject near and dear to my heart
it's clear that the 50 000 pages of
released church committee records
is pretty woefully incomplete for one
thing actually what's public now is only
the stuff directly related to
assassination plotting and the kennedy
assassination not the huge universe
of church committee files and all their
other investigations which remain sealed
to this day
but even within that more narrow focus i
i took the exercise one time of going
through those two reports and looking at
all the footnotes in them and counting
up the ones that the transcripts for
which for those was were not public and
there were 40 of them
um and many of them completely directly
related to you know the kennedy
assassination and things that should be
public
um i was talking with john mellen here
yesterday who says that if you look at
the drafts of some of the reports and
other materials there are yet other
interviews which are not even discussed
and those reports are mentioned and so
there's a whole universe of materials um
including interviews with customs
officials and other people that might
shed some light
on oswald's connection with us
intelligence agencies
so there's more there
the church committee spent some time
chasing down the rabbit hole of
allegations of cuban involvement in the
assassination and i think this is very
important because every investigation
that kennedy's murder has come again up
against this uh old and new allegations
that fidel castro was in some way behind
kennedy's murder
some of those stories are listed here if
you could see them they include gilberto
alvarado ogarte the warren commission
called him d
the nicaraguan undercover agent who said
he saw as well take 6 500 in the cuban
embassy in mexico city to kill kennedy
they include uh pedro gutierrez valencia
or credit examiner who saw kennedy
sarah oswald take money to kill kennedy
outside the cuban embassy
there's a story about a twist party with
the secretary and the cuban consulate
who dealt with oswald where they were
seen together
and and more stories some were some more
laughable than others including the
pedro charles letter
which was supposedly written to friendly
from inside cuba on november 10th
before the assassination but was
actually postmarked five days after the
assassination
um
the committee wrote writes about some of
these stories um and there are many more
that were unknown to the committee that
have been uh the house committee uh a
few years later dealt with
um
so an obvious question is are any of
them for real i mean it's pretty hard to
believe that oswald was taking money
both inside and outside the cuban
embassy to kill kennedy
so are they all after the fact
propaganda operations simply taking
advantage of jfk's death
to try to finger castro and get an added
benefit
and
i'm going to skip a little dan hardway
is quoted in gayton fonzie's book
with an interesting quote about
his belief that david phillips had a
connection to every single one of the uh
of the allegations that were coming
forth and maybe someone will ask him
about that today
i'm gonna
skip over that and talk just very
briefly about
this issue of the so-called mexico city
tapes it's a long convoluted story i'm
not going to have time to get into
but i want to make a couple points
to summarize uh in october of 1963 the
mexico city state cia station reported
the headquarters the visit an american
to the soviet embassy based on telephone
conversations of a man calling himself
lee oswald
and after the assassination the
transcripts of these tapes
would cause great consternation in the
halls of power in washington because in
one conversation oswald
made reference to a prior meeting with a
man named kostikov
valerie kostikov was kgb naturally but
much more ominously he was in the fbi
and ci files as being department 13
sabotage and assassinations
and also captured on tape was a cryptic
comment that this oswald made that led
some later to believe that the cubans
were housing him in mexico city while he
was there on his visit
and this is the context in which lyndon
johnson put together the warren
commission and bandied about the figure
of 40 million americans who would die in
a nuclear exchange with the soviets
so
um
transcripts of oswald's call what about
the tapes themselves
well the received story um is that the
tapes were erased routinely recycled
before the assassination
but the recycling story itself only
developed after
fbi director hoover told the white house
and the secret service in writing
that on november 23 these tapes are
still in existence fbi specializations
listen to them
they had oswald right there in the jail
cell in dallas and they determined it
wasn't his voice on the tapes
so oswald the loser who nobody ever
heard of is impersonated on tap
telephone lines in a foreign country
before the assassination in a manner
which connects them to soviet and cubans
interesting
anyway it turns out that back in 1976
oh yeah this is uh one of the memos that
went to the secret service about this
impossible to read
it turns out the church committee was
actually on to this story all the only
pursuit of little ways back in 1976
um regarding the fbi's assertion that
like the cia was saying at the time oh
the tapes had been routinely recycled
and it was all a big mistake nobody ever
really listened to them
staffer paul wallach wrote a memo saying
the staff submits that the matter is not
as simple as the bureau asserts
not as simple indeed much later two
warren commission staffers
would say that they
listened to these tapes in april of 1964
when they went down to mexico city as
part of the warren commission's
investigation although the idea of whose
voice was on the tapes was not even a
question that was on their minds
the church committee also didn't have
access to the recordings of lyndon
johnson
declassified only in the 1990s after the
passage of the jfk records act and some
of these calls are quite enlightening
the very first call president johnson
had with fbi director hoover on the
morning after the kennedy assassination
at 10 o'clock
johnson asked about mexico city and he
got this answer
no that's one angle that's very
confusing for this reason we have up
here the tape and the photograph
of the man who was at the soviet embassy
using oswald's name
and the picture and the tape do not
correspond to this man's voice nor to
his appearance in other words it appears
there's a second person it was at the
soviet embassy down there
and it turns out there's actually a
little problem with this tape too we
have the transcript but this
presidential phone call has itself been
erased as i discovered when i made a bit
of a pest of myself at the lbj library
in austin
and i'm wondering if somebody could
click the little speaker
icon i don't know if we're able to hear
it
volume maybe
there's not much to hear anyway
maybe the erasure has been erased
anyway
the
what there is is 14 minutes of basically
pure hiss
and i got a couple years of a phony
story from people at the lbj library
about johnson's vice presidential taping
equipment
being inadequate and that's why the
audio sounds like that seriously however
i pointed out to them that the phone
calls before and after on the same day
all sound fine and they repeated their
story
um
finally a couple years later i wrote an
essay about this on the history matters
website that i also run and i guess they
got a few letters and phone calls or
emails
because finally they sent me this memo
and i actually don't have the date of
the analysis port i couldn't paste this
but it was interesting that the date of
the audio engineering analysis which was
included in this letter it was actually
from a year before i first contacted
them so they were sitting on this for a
few years and basically it's a very
short engineering report
the gist of which is
uh quote most likely the belt was
intentionally erased by rubbing it
against the uh
magnet included in most models of the
many belt machines but a small portion
was missed because you can hear a little
clicking of voices periodically in the
tape
and uh
i find this interesting you know the the
nixon 18 minute tape gap consumed
america for over a year and a half and i
uh
did my bit to try to get the story about
this this thing out and to me
the idea that in a race presidential
phone call from less than 24 hours after
kennedy's murder has not been a major
news story is sort of emblematic of why
we're here today
uh in some i guess i'd just like to say
that i think the church committee
investigation was a rare and worthy
endeavor um happened kind of at a unique
time which i think enabled it to happen
um
there are many people
in the past and today who willingly see
great power to secret agencies in the
name of fighting bad guys
and i would suggest that they might do
well to read the reports of the church
committee to see what happened last time
around
thank you
any questions sure
[Applause]
questions
leonard marowski is my mine i'm a
licensed private detective here in
pennsylvania has anyone considered
john kennedy's executive orders may have
contributed or been the nail in the
coffin
for the decision makers to finally
decide to take him out
uh is
are you referring a particular executive
order or well are uh there's i
understand there was one that may have
begun the dismantling of the federal
reserve
yeah i mean you know the
i mean i guess i'll say two things one
is that
working strictly for a motive for murder
when you have somebody like john kennedy
or any president is problematic because
you can find it everywhere you know this
is we have mafia theories cia joint
chiefs of staff you name it
but i do agree in general that it's been
striking to me how
you know i follow a lot of the story of
the declassified records and what new
things come out and the amount of stuff
related to ken and kennedy foreign
policy
decisions
um
you know some of it known at the time
but it's come out in drips and drabs
over the years and the picture you know
if you read books now on uh vietnam
history from that era they've all been
subtly changing over time it was all
like kennedy and johnson were like you
know cut from the same cloth for years
and years and years and there was a
funny gap in the pentagon papers you
know during the transition
and the story has emerged that
regardless of the sort of i guess
unknowable question i suppose of what
might have happened had kennedy live
it's absolutely clear now that there
were black and white withdrawal plans on
the books kennedy was serious about them
they actually began them in october of
63 and and uh the
the
i talked about the april of 63 plans for
withdrawal vietnam in november 20th
there was the last meeting while kennedy
was alive you know on his trip
um and there were no change in those
plans at that time so i'm not trying to
say vietnam is the answer that's one of
many areas in foreign policy where the
landscape was changing and the people
who look for motive for murder there
it's a rich field
yes i was curious whether you thought
that um with all the impersonations of
oswald and with uh what was going on
with the church committee finding out
about the impersonation so and so forth
do you think this possibly led to
operation northwoods really becoming
assassination of president kennedy um
that's a lot of speculation that married
these days i try not to speculate too
much but i will pose a question suppose
uh on november 22nd in the afternoon
oswald uh doesn't show up capture in the
texas theater but he's dead on the
streets of dallas
and maybe there's you know if he's in
his pocket or who knows what
um
and there are now tapes of a man using
his name down mexico city and he's dead
and nobody's going to compare do voice
comparisons on these tapes now
the whole landscape of what happened in
the aftermath might be a very different
scarier thing than we
than actually happened
could you could we we'll take this if we
have time we'll come back to you okay
uh
i wondered rex if you've uh
heard about the um
charlie battaglia who was in charge of
the select subcommittee on intelligence
at the time of
the review board
investigation
uh
and the fact that both nara and the
review board
both
suffered
extreme roadblocking
for access to a lot of these documents
and in the end they came up with a very
temporary a very
it was a very poor compromise because
they they were allowed just three days
with interns
to do the research to look at the the
extra material
and in the end i don't think they got
anywhere near i mean we talked yesterday
about the eight
eight binders
the indexing to the church committee
which in my opinion should be should be
released
and i know joan asked
judge tunnheim i think the last time you
had a conference man
about um
whether you know when when was the
church why wasn't you know the balance
of the church committee farms weren't
they
released so that's what that yeah i i
agree i mean the you know there are what
five or six million pages in the
so-called jfk collection so a huge
universe of documents were released but
um depending on you know where you draw
your umbrella uh
and even a conservative drawing of that
there's many areas in which stuff is
still not there
of missing documents from the church
files and they sought to explain 50
pieces of missing testimony to me and in
the end they acknowledged yeah there
were 33 pieces of missing testimony
um
two things you mentioned uh one the
november 22nd meeting in i think you
said it was brazil desmond fitzgerald
saying he was acting on that that
meeting i was actually in paris
in paris but but actually on behalf of
rfk right he claims
uh and then the the memo from katzenback
on the 25th which obviously suggests
very quickly the desire for a cover-up
or a desire to sort of
smooth this over i'm wondering is there
anything in the documentary trail that
shows what rfk is doing saying thinking
during those
few days immediately after the
assassination i mean he's still the
attorney general
should probably talk to the guy next to
you but but in general um
you know
in terms of official actions he's pretty
hands off he's grieving and katzenbach
is you know running with the ball on
that um but you know behind the scenes
there's a he you know the afternoon the
assassination itself he's at hickory
hill uh john mccone comes up and they
talk for a few hours
um he makes a phone call to uh
haynes johnson and harry reis williams
who are part of this whole cuban
operation stuff he's involved in and
says to them one of your guys did this
and the precise meaning of that is can
still be debated um but
the whole question of robert kennedy's
reaction and his
general silence on it i think is a
fascinating topic which uh
i'm not sure it's anybody's ever gotten
quite to the bottom of it but um you
know the
uh
i don't know
reed brothers though for uh uh for a
good good overview of that
it's all there's also a story that's in
david's book and was also in uh
a book previously
that
robert and jackie sent william walton a
family friend as a personal emissary to
moscow
a week after the assassination
to deliver the news to khrushchev that
we know this wasn't you guys this was a
big domestic plot and
bobby's going to try to become president
later and carry on john's work
which is an amazing story
we are out of time uh so thank you very
much rex